[Music]
give it a break could you please just
give it a break for two weeks
and see if we can all work together and
if we're all working together
you're going to be surprised how much
good that we can do
a passionate plea there from governor
sisilak earlier tonight
urging nevadans to stop the divisiveness
as we deal with a big surge in
coronavirus cases
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis the governor
announcing what he calls stay at home
2.0 it asks everyone to buckle down and
prevent further spread of the virus
statewide
madison kimbrough is live tonight with
more on what that means for
nevadans madison
yeah so monday marked the highest
hospitalization rate since
mid-august and governor sysolak is
saying if he doesn't see a change within
the next two weeks
he's going to be forced to take stronger
action
i'm not bluffing i'm not playing a game
we are in a very
crucial point right now tuesday night
governor sisilak provided updates on how
the state of nevada will go
forward in the fight against the
coronavirus stating that nevadans need
to accept and understand this reality
now
and change their behavior immediately in
the next two weeks
we must see a significant reversal of
the current trends
which are deeply concerning now nevadans
need to operate in the stay-at-home 2.0
mentality
to get things under control so our
public health
response infrastructure can catch up we
need that time to bring testing
timelines down
catch up on contact racing and relieve
our health care infrastructure system
while the governor was encouraged by the
recent news of a coronavirus vaccine
he made it clear that we cannot wait for
a potential vaccine to get this deadly
virus
back into a manageable level if
employees can do their jobs from home
have them do so for the next two weeks
if employees have to be in the workspace
they need to be masked at all times
this past monday marked the highest
hospitalization rate since mid-august
in nevada with 1326 people diagnosed per
day
the governor harped on the message that
face coverings must be worn by
everyone in meetings of two or more
people for the entire duration
he also asked that local airports and
colleges step up enforcement of mask
wearing
saying that compliance in the airports
is falling short and that it's mandatory
to wear your mask inside
after the two-week stay-at-home 2.0
order the governor will reconvene and
see if there has been any progress with
the decline of cases
and then decide what is next for our
state
now the governor was also joined by dr
tony slonam now he's the ceo of renowned
health
a facility that would be providing
alternate care units to accommodate
more beds for coven 19 patients
reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now all right so one more time
here here are the urgent requests
from our governor go out only if you
have to
reduce your time in public to what is
only necessary limit
any and all exposure to those who are
outside your household
avoid gatherings large and small and do
not have dinners or parties
try and telework as much as possible and
if you have to be in the workplace
wear a mask all the time now we can't
stress how serious the situation is and
if it doesn't get better in a couple of
weeks
restrictions could get much deeper than
that